florida is also a crucial state to watch
tonight for president trump it is
central
to his path to victory the swing state
is a toss-up the latest cbs news
battleground tracker poll
shows former vice president biden
leading within the margin of error
manuel bojorquez is outside a polling
place
in miami manuel when could we expect
results from florida
well they could come by tonight of
course because here in florida not only
do we have the voters showing up today
but the state started processing and
counting ballots more than
three weeks ago so hopefully by tonight
we will have a pretty clear idea
of who will win this critical state now
let's talk some numbers nearly 64
percent
of registered voters here cast their
ballot before today
shattering in-person and mail-in ballot
voting records you may recall in 2016
president trump won florida's 29
electoral votes by just one percentage
point
the black and latino votes could be
crucial in winning this state
this time around biden's support among
black voters is higher than hillary
clinton's was
in 2016 and he leads among latino voters
latinos make up just over 17 percent of
registered voters in florida the largest
among battleground states
but president trump has strong support
among cuban americans and in 2016
he won white voters with college degrees
by double digits
cbs news polling last month showed that
biden is now pretty much neck and neck
with the president
among that demographic gail
all right manuel thank you